joining me now is
uh republican senator of south carolina
lindsey graham senator thank you so much
for being here tonight i know that you
were at the border in arizona last week
we will talk about that in just a second
but first your reaction to
this crisis that we've seen before now
under the biden administration
well the worst is yet to come the bible
administration's done everything but put
a neon
sign flashing come on in
i was just dumbfounded by what i found
at the border
the asylum seekers are coming again so
what happened in the old system if you
could get one foot katie into the united
states
and claimed asylum you would be
processed in the united states
you would be released and your court
date would be four years in the future
nobody would ever show up ankle braces
included
so what did trump do he said if you come
here seeking asylum we're going to keep
you in mexico
and you've got to wait there to court
here and guess what people are not going
to pay 20 thousand dollars
to come from central america to set
mexico for four years
so it shut the asylum claims off they're
about to do away with the remaining
mexico policy
the word is out all over central america
uh that the asylum laws are about to
change
deportations are stopping and they
literally have stopped building the wall
there's a section of wall near nogales
arizona on the mexican u.s
border where they have holes in the wall
big enough to get tank columns through
the the panel is sitting there waiting
to be put up but they just won't put it
up
so this is a formula for disaster it's a
witch's brew
and the biden administration is clueless
when it comes to what they're doing
you know senator i think the american
people get very frustrated with this
topic because
it's a big complex topic that gets
politicized for elections and therefore
nothing ever gets done and we continue
to have these conversations
about the crisis and i want to talk
tonight about what we're seeing
right now in places like texas with
unaccompanied minors getting to
the border last in january last month 5
800 of them
let's talk about how they don't just
show up at the border they're not
getting dropped off by
their parents they're getting smuggled
to the border their parents are not with
them
and then they are oftentimes at least
during the obama administration getting
placed with sponsors
who happen to be sex offenders or
exploiting them for labor purposes
so now here we are with the biden white
house saying
we have to keep these people and these
children in these facilities which they
previously called
concentration camps because we have this
problem
so talk about that the issue of
unaccompanied minors specifically since
we're seeing that spike
okay number one word is out in central
america that the policies are changing
so uh during the trump administration we
would take the unaccompanied
minor and we'd send them back to their
home country we actually had agreements
with the northern triangle countries
that you could apply for asylum there
regarding the united states and you
never have to come into our country
and we also had an agreement to send the
kids back so what you see
is you see thousands of unaccompanied
minors coming to our border
turning themselves in we're going to
hold them and release them into the
country
98 percent of them will stay in america
and here's the untold story
most of them have family in the united
states this
is a business and the cartels are in
this business big time
and a lot of these girls are getting
abused and what what the binding
administration is doing
is they're turning on the faucet again
at every level
and people are responding and it's a
real tragedy in the making
well many of the family members who are
here are here
illegally but i want to talk about the
democrats hypocrisy on this because
they've used some very incendiary
rhetoric the trump the biden
campaign uses rhetoric to beat donald
trump they use the compassionate
argument let's play
some of what democrats have said about
these facilities that the dividing
administration now is using
the united states is running
concentration camps on our southern
border
and that is exactly
what they are they are concentration
camps these are like concentration camps
and i'm not afraid to use that word
there are camps and people are being
concentrated this is very simple
for 40 years before auschwitz we had
concentration camps what we're doing now
fits very cleanly inside that tradition
so senator they're now calling the same
exact facilities
influx centers now that it's biden yeah
yeah hypocrisy runs rampant here so
kamala harris
when she was running for president
actually protested outside of the
miami facility where they were holding
unaccompanied minors
that facility is now open aoc called the
facility in texas a concentration camp
at least she's consistent about
complaining but i just got back from the
border
i spent time with the border patrol
agents the customs and border agents who
secure our border and collect the
customs and duties
and protect us it was miserable for them
to be compared
to nazi concentration camp guards
these people are great patriotic
americans
doing the best they can being
overwhelmed and to be treated that way
is just unbelievable
but where are these critics now where
are you now the bible administration is
doing the same damn thing
so here's my suggestion the body
administration look at the trump
policies that worked
reimplement them sit down with
republicans like me and see if we can
fix the thing
yeah well you mentioned where are the
critics where have they been where are
they now they've been there in the past
you had glenn greenwald tweeting
about this exact thing with the media he
said it's not an exaggeration i've seen
more news articles in the last 48 hours
discussing how complex difficult
challenging and vexing is the problem of
miners and other immigrants at the
border
than i did in the prior four years
combined wonder why
this reminds me of 2014 when town hall
where i work
where i write and report on a lot of
issues we published some of the first
photos from these initial
crisis when it came to unaccompanied
minors so why is it that all of a sudden
the media is changing their tune
because trump is gone trump actually
found a way to work with mexico to help
everybody
he mexico said okay we'll take care of
these asylum seekers so they don't
overrun your country
you help us he actually had agreements
with uh northern triangle nations like
honduras where you could apply for
asylum
there and not overrun our border he
actually improved the economies of the
northern triangle countries
the the criticism against trump was over
the top
and here's what's so sad and quite
frankly dangerous
biden is undoing everything that trump
did that worked
there's a disaster in the making at the
border if they don't change these
policies
by the summer there's going to be a
million people overrun our border
their girls are going to be taken down
these trails and raped and abused and
again the body administration has done
everything they can
but put up a neon sign on the border
saying come on in
all right well we'll leave it there
obviously this is something that many
administrations have struggled with that
congress has struggled with and we will
certainly be following in the future
senator graham thank you so much
thank you